عاد الى بلدته محمول على اكتاف رفاق
السلاح الاف الاردنيين شيعوا في الكثير
بمحافظه جرش شمال العاصمه جثمان العقيد
عبد الرزاق الدلابيح نائب مدير شرطه
محافظه معان الذي قضى برصاصه في الراس في
منطقه الحسينيه جنوبا قبيلته منحه الحكومه
ثلاثه ايام لمعرفه قاتل ابنها ورفضت
استقبال اعضاء الحكومه ومجلس الامه
هو القاتل وانه ال- الحكومه الاردنيه غير
ممثل وغير مرحل فيها نتيجه تشارك في هذا
العزاء
والى الجنوب الاردني في الحسينيه التي
كانت مسرحا للاشتباك بين قوات الدرك ومن
سماهم الامن خارجين عن القانون يبحث الامن
عن الادله لمعرفه مطلقين الرصاص تطور يوصف
بالخطير هنا الاحتجاج ضد رفع اسعار
المحروقات عقبه اسبوعين على اضراب سائقي
الشاحنات بسبب عدم قدرتهم على تحمل المزيد
من غلاء المشتقات النفطيه
ليله الجمعه كانت دمويه في الحسينيه
وشاهدت غضبا ايضا عبر اغلاق الطرق وحرق
الاطارات في كل من ناعور وما ادبه
والزرقاء والكرك وعجلون ومدن وقرن اردنيه
اخرى
في مناطق اللي تشهد اعمال العنف وراح يكون
في اجراءات قريبه في هذه المناطق
لكن هذه الاجراءات هي فقط موجهه لمن
يستخدم العنف
استعاد الامن وسيطرته على الخط الصحراوي
عبر تعزيز حضوره في المدن القريبه من هذا
الخط وفي هذه المشاهد يرافق الامن حافلات
وسيارات تقل سياحا وجهتهم العقبه كما هو
الحال بالنسبه الى تامين حركه الشاحنه من
والى الميناء الاردني الوحيد في العقبه
توعد الامن بتجديد قبضته لحمايه الارواح
والممتلكات في البلاد فيما وجهت انتقادات
اذاعه للحكومه التي دخلت على خط الازمه
متاخره براي منتقديها ولم تقدم حلولا
حقيقيه لهذه الازمه المفتوحه منذ بدايه
الشهر ذروه الاشتباكات مع الامن التي قضى
فيها العقيد الدلابيح كانت في هذا الشارع
قوات الدرك في كل مكان على امتداد الطريق
الصحراوي والمشهد الامني يهيمن على مالت
اليه الاحتجاجات على رفع اسعار المحروقات
حسن الشوبك على الجزيره الحسينيه الجنوبيه
الاردن